hey since hands two new shirts today one
limited-edition one permanent this
month's limited-edition sin shirt
commemorates a sin from the 2012 video
during the dramatic and unlikely plane
escapes the explosion scene there are a
limited number of these shirts so if you
want one go now the new permanent shirt
in our cinemasins store commemorates one
of our favorite and most frequently
asked about sins to do the something ex
machina sin since we always change out
the first word in our deus ex machina
references the shirt reads blank ex
machina you can fill in your favorite
one with your mind your head and your
mind and your brain next month we'll
have a new limited shirt and there's
also another new permanent shirt on the
way please let us know in the comments
of this video which sin you would prefer
to see on next month's limited shirt and
if you want to buy one of these things
is serious